our next question is from Suzanne and
Munich Germany I love writing a lot and
I write a gratitude journal every day I
tried to do it on my computer but it
doesn't feel natural I want to be
disconnected when I do so now I have a
big collection of journals from the past
years and simply cannot get rid of them
I thought about scanning them but it
doesn't feel right to read them on my
computer and I do read them from time to
time and feel amazing about all the
credit you'd do you have any advice so
do we have any advice I mean here's some
things I probably would have told
Georgia on on the last voicemail but I
think these apply just as much to to
Suzanne so she said she's tried to write
on the computer but it doesn't feel
natural mm-hmm
nothing feels natural first was the
first time you've done it right first
time I played basketball it didn't feel
natural to me right and I think that's
true the first time I wrote a sentence
it didn't feel natural to me first time
I tried to write a book it sure as hell
didn't feel natural to me the first time
I wrote a blog post it didn't feel
natural to me what feels natural is
something we've done for a long time
that all of a sudden seems natural to us
but it took a long time to build up that
skill it doesn't mean you don't have the
talent for it it means you you took time
to to gratitude journal every single day
so something I would recommend and this
could apply it to Georgia as well but
for Suzanne I think that that you
probably want to write about the
experience and the emotions you're
feeling of letting go and one of the
things you can do is start a blog and
and maybe you can keep it a private blog
even if you want and unless you want to
make a public which i think is great
you can learn out loud as we say and
actually Sean can you put a link we
someone who asked us how we started our
blog we have a blog post called how to
start a successful blog now you can
redefine success in a bunch of different
ways it doesn't mean having millions of
readers it can mean that you're doing it
every day or that you're learning a lot
in public and so the first thing I'll
recommend yeah is is write in public if
you can write and then some other
practical tips why not take pictures or
scan those journals or and yeah they
said wow I don't know if I'm about doing
all of them why don't you just do one
and keep the journal see how it feels
and then
anytime you need to go back and
reference that one journal go back and
reference it online first and by the way
some of the ones that you scan you can
make them searchable so you don't have
to flip through a hundred different
pages to find what you want so and if
you don't to scan it yourself you don't
rip out the pages there are places that
you can skin will scan you can send your
your your journals or whatever off
they'll scan it for you
and either send it back to you or you
can have them dispose of it as well
let's put a link to at least one of the
scanning places that we've we've had
recommended to us recently so Shawn if
you could do that and then on top of
that when it comes to the the physical
things getting back to to Georgia is
maybe take a picture of some of the
things you're letting go of if you're
still trying to hold on to those
triggers of memories you know I don't
want to lose the I know the memories are
the things but I want to hold on to
these triggers even of the journals yeah
then you could take a picture of it and
I think you can let go yeah some
questions that I would ask Susan Ryan
you some what you think about these why
are you asking this question yeah and
and for me it's it's sounds to me like
maybe you want to get rid of these
journals or maybe you want to know what
you should want does that make sense
it does I think so I well I guess let me
let me rephrase it
maybe she thinks like I should want to
get rid of these journals right like I
was just thinking that sometimes someone
who's like okay
you know what I'm going to be a
minimalist I'm gonna play this this
velocity of my philosophy to my life and
Josh and Ryan they don't have a lot of
journals right so I shouldn't have a lot
of journals right so I should want to
get rid of these but I really don't want
to yeah is that kind of worries
absolutely and maybe she actually does
one of your and maybe there are burden
to her but if they're not a burden to
you then here's your permission to hold
on to him pleases you you don't have to
feel compelled to get rid of everything
to be a minimalist in fact I think about
our friend Drew who did the music for
our documentary minimalism he has this
he's book getting ready to the
Kickstarter project for this really nice
handcrafted journal that has like a
refillable liner and a
and it's gorgeous he showed me like a
preliminary video - it is beautiful
and he's III like to have one journal on
my desk and he I here for my sketches
and everything so I want it to be one
really high quality beautiful item but
also I can replace and remove the
inserts and put them on my shelf so I
can go back and reference them because I
use this all the time for my work I'm
like that sounds awesome and you a you
don't to justify it to me but it sounds
to me like that would make sense and if
I needed to work in that same way that I
would want the same thing a beautiful
object that I found value in and it
sounds like Suzanne finds value and the
more value in the act of journaling than
she does in the object itself the object
is just a vehicle that provides the
value and so maybe a blog could be just
as good of an answer and it could allow
her to expose her gratitude in public
and maybe just maybe that'll help other
people as well yeah absolutely you know
the question that that I would ask Susan
Suzanne here is are these causing more
pain than pleasure yeah is it a net
positive or negative that's I mean that
is that's only for Susanna no for me
it'd be a net negative because I don't
want to have a bookshelf full of
journalists that's my preference and
preferences or what make the world go
around that's right so if Susan's
preference if she if she prefers to have
a bookshelf full of her journals then
you know then you know that's great I
mean she's obviously asking this
question because she feels a little bit
of a little bit of pain so again she's
got to look at it and say is am i
experiencing more pain than I am
pleasure here like I thought about when
I was answering her question I thought
man my car it causes me a lot of pain
like I gotta like get the oil changed
it's it's it's an older car like you
know leaks when it rains mm-hmm that's
why we moved to Los Angeles just so your
card stopped exactly although for some
reason I had this rough spot that is
Lake I gotta get something again gotta
do something about this rough spot
moving to LA next to the ocean like it
is this rust is like spreading pretty
quickly oh wow
so there's all this pain associated with
my car but well hey I'm not gonna get
rid of it because la is a driving city
unfortunately I'm not going to go into
to get another car right but ultimately
you know there are these reasons I have
to keep my car even though it cause
causes me pain it is a net positive for
me to have in my life yeah so so that's
really I think where Susan needs to look
you know the other thing too is are the
rules that she can set up for herself
with these journals are there boundaries
that she can set up that maybe it's
somewhere in the middle of scanning and
getting rid of every single physical
journal yeah and then not doing anything
right you know where is the middle
ground she could let's see I've got some
stuff written down here um so if it was
me I'd look at okay because she said she
just go back to me she reads them which
is great like I've never went back and
read any of my journal stuff but in the
only thing I'll push back on on Suzanne
about here is do you actually do that or
is it an aspirational thing right
sometimes we we get books or whatever we
have journals because we aspire to do
something I aspire to go back and look
at that but do I actually do it yeah so
she said you know and I sometimes go
back to read the journals does that
really mean and one day I know I'm gonna
want to go back and read these journals
you're absolutely right and do you get
value from the next question right yeah
actually get value from going back or do
you do it out of a sense of obligation
so so you know let's say that she is
actively reading some of these entries
let's make that assumption that's what
she said in the voicemail so let's just
make that assumption that she is going
back and she's experiencing some of
these gratitude journal entries that
she's written in the past I would say
again like which ones hasn't she read in
a while or haven't read it all like you
could start there that's a boundary I'm
gonna get rid of all the journals I
haven't even looked at or what which
ones does she keep going back to like
could she make like you know a best of
best of gratitude moments and maybe blog
about that in public again can you
imagine right if you and I just did our
blog in private like in a journal yeah
like how much how much we would have
wasted not helping other people like our
attention our time our talent our skills
if we would have just done like we would
has come we will come in this room at
once a week and just have this
conversation and not publish the podcast
there would be a bunch of people who
weren't getting value from now again you
you have to realize now everything you
write is interesting but what are the
interesting parts from those journals
maybe the but best of is such a great
way to convey that to the world in the
world will give value out of them yeah
dude I was thinking she could like she
could create a boundary like okay here
the top 50 things that I'm grateful for
yeah anytime
I'm having a bad day I'm feeling upset I
can go to this list of 50 things and
remind myself why I am so grateful and
maybe you know some things will fall off
and other things would add it to that
list but I'm just encouraging Suzanne
here to again create some boundaries
around these journals a you know or I
guess like the first question I would
ask myself if I was Suzanne is what am I
getting out of keeping these journals
and then what am I gonna get out of it
if I get rid of these journals like
she's got to ask yourself questions like
that to figure out what her what her
exact preferences and what's gonna make
her feel best about about these journals
there's not one right way to do it I
wish I could be like you know what Oh
Suzanne thank you for that journal
question Josh and I just wrote an essay
on this the perfect amount of journals
they have is 10 journals because that's
way too many for me right right and it
may not be enough for her and so the
question then is what is enough and I
think row that's what minimalism is it's
the art of having enough yeah
Suzanne I'd love to send you a copy of
the the German version of minimalism
live a meaningful life it just came out
in Germany and it's it I believe it's in
German I wasn't able to read all the
words in it but it certainly looked
German to me it's my favorite cover that
we've ever had I'm looking I'm looking
forward to seeing the physical version
hasn't shown up here at the studio yet
but it's in Germany now so yeah
minimalism live a meaningful life in
Germany as soon as we get a physical
copy of that in Shawn if you could send
it to her or if she wants the audio book
it's not in German but if he wants that
we have to send her an audio book
version of minimalism live a meaningful
life
you